we also have a rematch of a Sunday night
game from earlier this year between the
Cowboys and the Eagles the Cowboys had
one of their best performances of the
year that night they're going to need it
again if they want to nail down the
division when they go to Philadelphia
and we've been saying for weeks that the
a that the NFC East is going to come
down to week 16 Dallas at Philadelphia
if the Cowboys win they win the division
if the Eagles win they still have to
take care of some business week 17 but
this is the focal point this is the big
game of the week as it relates to
playoff implications and the Cowboys
have an injury to be concerned about and
that is dak Prescott shoulder Cris he
was injured on a seven yard run on the
second series of the game he was tackled
by Clay Matthews he didn't miss a play
and dak Prescott has never missed a game
but there's a concern and Ezekiel
Elliott let the cat out of the bag
yesterday I knew it was I saw it but
sorry go cjoynt go ahead AC joint injury
to dak Prescott and look what what what
are the challenges of trying to throw a
football when your shoulders banged up
that one yeah it is it's a bothersome
you know I've heard my AC joint before
now it depends on the severity of the
you know the sprain of the AC joint and
all of that but you know just to lift
your arm up that's the thing that hurts
you the most there's so many muscles
that connect into that AC joint that it
really bothers you to get that elbow up
there to make the proper throw and do
those type of things and just vitally
important that he can throw the ball
effectively not only I mean we're
expecting cold weather in the Northeast
this weekend so he's gonna have that but
I mean the Philadelphia Eagles that's
not the team again we want the Cowboys
to run the ball but I don't think you
can just sit there and go oh we're gonna
run the ball on the Philadelphia Eagles
I mean there's no definite there that's
the one of the strengths of their
football team is slowing down the run
game and one of the weaknesses of their
team here as the latest threat is their
secondary and they're going to have to
make some plays in the pass game so
that's where this is a crucial injury to
make sure he doesn't leave yards or
completions out on the field because
he's less than dealing with this AC
joint but I saw it Mike when it happened
and even as I was watching the game in
real-time
I could tell it bothered him because if
you watch the replay again - and I
always look in this if we could show it
watch when he gets up watch when he gets
up he doesn't move his right arm he lets
it like just hang there he'll kind of do
a shoulder thing with his left arm but
his right arm he just keeps it real
still like he flips it back and look he
kind of listen hang down and he doesn't
move I don't know you know maybe I'm
being picky there maybe I've seen too
many guys over the years but I thought I
saw it and then even got in the huddle I
thought he made a little reference to it
once again but definitely a little scary
for the Cowboys here's Jason Garrett
coach to the Cowboys talking about dak
Prescott status for Sunday at
Philadelphia yeah they did an MRI and
everything seems to be okay
but he just banged it up and it's hard
for him to function right now so don't
anticipate him throwing much in practice
today concerned about the injury sort of
piling up on tack and
the effective of wormans at some point
not really he's a pretty tough
individual we'll be ready to go one of
the most overlooked qualities and
characteristics of a franchise
quarterback the ability to play each and
every week and for some it's going to be
through injury he's never missed a game
in his entire career 62 for 62 he's two
games away from completing his rookie
contract there is no way he's gonna miss
this one and you mentioned the weather
for Philadelphia on Sunday late
afternoon low 40s no win no sanitation
so that'll be a little bit better by the
end of the game it'll be close to
freezing so it's gonna drop about 10
degrees between the three hours from
kickoff to conclusion but once you get
you know once you get lathered up once
you get the sweat going once you get
things worked out I think that he'll be
okay but but you know we just don't know
and it's not like they have to tell us
they don't have to tell us the results
of the MRI they don't have to tell us
that he's gonna be okay all they tell us
is did he practice if so was he limited
did he fully participate that's all they
have to tell us Wednesday and Thursday
and Friday they just have to apply a
label or no label at all questionable
doubtful out or no label which means
he's good to go they don't have to get
into the details as to how it's gonna
affect him throwing the football and
that's really gonna be the thing to see
and that's we're gonna have to watch
early in the game how does he look
throwing the ball does it seem like he's
got limitations or he's he able to do
everything he needs to do or is it gonna
be an easy q Elliot day right and if
you're the Eagles if you're jim schwartz
the defensive coordinator do you design
that defense to take away as he co
elliot and four stack Prescott to show
you that he can throw well I think
that's one of the things you look for
early on to go what does it look like
when Dax throwing the ball deep and
doing things like that aggressively and
then maybe you can change how you want
to attack them you know from that
standpoint on if you feel like oh you
could tell there's some tenderness or
some grimacing going on when he throws
the ball plus 20 yards or something like
that yeah then maybe you do get a little
bit more aggressive with some of your
defensive cause my big thing is this the
Dallas Cowboys have all the pressure in
the world on them in this game they
should win this game they're the better
team they are more talented the
Philadelphia Eagles have a
get-out-of-jail-free card
banged up there's no weapons around
carson wentz they're not supposed to win
this game as we saw yes the first
meeting in Dallas first Philadelphia one
of the best games of the year for the
Dallas Cowboys
last week was probably the best game and
we see when Dallas is hitting on all
cylinders they're as good as anybody in
football the problem is they don't hit
on all cylinders very much and they
should win this football game I mean
they really should the Eagles are not
playing well on defense and their
formula on offense is throw to the tight
ends and throw to the two running backs
mile Sanders Boston Scott got hurts for
a bunch of five and eight yard throws if
the Dallas Cowboys can't win this game
then you know really they all deserve to
be fired down there there's nothing I
could say more than that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports